getting what you asked for is now racist
Sanctuary City leader is whining on
National Television over why he's
getting busloads of illegals instead of
Consulting a dictionary and looking up
the word Sanctuary Chicago's farle mayor
Brandon Johnson's taking the easier
route by saying Texas governor Greg
Abbott hates black
people the governor of Texas is
committed to causing chaos he is
attacking democratically ran cities and
particularly cities that are being led
um by black leaders or leaders of color
this is unconscionable I it's a very
raggedy approach and quite frankly not
only is it Reckless and Raggedy um but
it is evil
spirited Harold everything is racist
here you have of a person of color
crying racism when people of color are
sent to his
City isn't he the racist then if he's
saying please no more brown
people I I don't you ready I don't think
think that this is racist what governor
Abbott is doing I've said before I think
this is a uh politically it's ingenious
uh substantively uh I'm I hope that the
governors of all Stripes political
stripes and political ideologies will
say this is what we need to be doing
more of in Washington um let us be clear
where we are the Congress and the Senate
and the president are trying to
negotiate a deal to do three things to
help uh fortify and and and bring some
sanity to what's happening in our border
and to find ways to fund our friends in
Israel as they fight Hamas and find ways
to fund the ukrainians as they try to
push back Putin we've been it's been
weeks now October 7th obviously was the
invasion from Hamas and Israel we're now
past we're into the new year and we have
we're still at a standstill because
these clowns in Washington can't come
together and figure out how do we
appropriate money and how do we figure
out what the new policy should be that
mayor is wrong and I hope that perhaps
his words are are inter interpreted by
those who are adults and serious in
Washington uh and for that matter in
politics to do something um and Governor
Abbott is much as you may think that he
has he is being politically shrewd or
he's making uh a hay for bad political
hay for cities like New York and Chicago
if I were the governor of Texas I'd be
doing the same thing if I were the
governor of Arizona or a state where you
had more and more people coming across
and you could not sustain it you send
those people to places where they can't
sustain it and more importantly Greg I
would agree with you wholeheartedly here
these are people that for a long time
said they wanted exactly these things so
I think you're right there thank you so
much that's all I needed to hear you
could have skipped all that stuff yeah
just oh my God all right you know Dana
remember how the left always cries about
fairness and now Abbott spreads the
burden which is an elemental to Fair how
how unfair they implode they only want
fairness when they get the money when
they get the jobs but not when it comes
to the responsibilities of being a
neighbor CBS had a poll over the weekend
that said 68% of Americans disapprove of
the administration on immigration 63%
want them to be tougher 7% said they
think everything's fine so the White
House has looked at that and said you
know what the 7% they got something
right let's go with the 7% this makes a
lot of sense the governor of Texas has
also sent many migrants to Denver and
Las Vegas guess what those Mayors are
white y Okay so that argument goes away
the the Democrats these mayors that are
not banding together as a group they
would be more powerful if they did this
band together as a group and demand that
the White House do something they're
doing the Biden Administration no favors
and themselves no favors I believe that
Brandon Johnson is is Johnson is at a
28% approval rating which is no bueno no
o that's Spanish for not good youro see
going to Spain really helped
you Jesse uh I'm going to take mayor
Johnson's lead and go you know why he's
attacking Governor Abbott cuz he's in a
wheelchair he's ableist yeah he's
ableist he's attacking him because he's
in a wheelchair you don't hear Abbott
saying that do you no you don't no you
do not Gutfeld when I go to a Knicks
game and play lousy defense and they
give up 140 points you know what I do
what do you do I Boo the Knicks am I
attacking black basketball players when
I'm booing the Knicks no
well
actually the dicks organization chose
those black players they drafted them
they got them through trades just as
these cities have chosen black leaders
to represent them as Mayors okay
Greg I believe the the governor of
Florida sent the migrants to Martha's
Vineyard they have a white mayor in
Martha's Vineyard I believe if the
Abbott had sent him to New York a couple
years ago DeBlasio would have been here
I believe Blasio is pretty white this
has nothing to do with race it has
everything to do with them ducking
accountability and the word has gone out
on the Democrat side you must blame
Abbott you must not blame Biden because
if you do blame Biden he will indict you
like they did to our guy here judge
until these cities abandon their
Sanctuary status they're just going to
come off as hypocritical buffoons they
they can't admit that the stance was
only adopted because they pretty much
assumed they'd never be called on it
yeah they assumed they'd never be called
on it and in addition to you know Martha
vineard and and and Denver I mean you've
got Chicago Philadelphia Washington New
York City Atlanta Baltimore Los Angeles
all Sanctuary cities all black Mayors so
should he not send people to those
cities should he discriminate and why
all of a sudden is it if you're black
you cannot be made accountable claudian
gay she's not accountable because of her
saying that you know the the code of
conduct is not violated if you say you
want to kill all the Jews or because of
plagiarism she she was criticized
because she was black and this mayor is
criticizing is he's saying you're
criticizing me because I'm black and the
truth is they're saying if I'm black you
can't remove me if you're Claudine you
can't include me if I'm the mayor of
Chicago it's used in a way to prevent
them from being accountable and they say
they are victims because of their color
when in truth what the blacks are now
saying is I am privileged
I am privil black privileg Harold it's
black privilege you cannot remove me I
am not accountable and the classic
example is kamla Harris I mean she's
wonderful uh she's hasn't done anything
that we can think of but you know you
can't criticize her because she's black
please denounce your black privilege
right here on the show har J I will
gladly accept White
Privilege substitute for the black
privilege you guys are talking
about that's great you have a choice of
two so do I no you're 1% get hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else